learn and John I'm currently at a lot of
right because it's very hot here also
because my life it's amazing and
marvelous and one of the other things
are speaking my life amazing and
marvelous these days is that very soon
we will have for the first time non
horribly blurry pictures from Pluto New
Horizons have been traveling for nine
years as launched in 2006 in addition to
contaminating a bunch of the signs of
experiments specs graphs cameras that
kind of thing is also carrying the ashes
of Clyde Tombaugh the guy who discovered
Pluto which is pretty cool he gets a
like actually goes there's gonna be
conversation about into the comments
another one I just got to say Pluto's
not a planet and the rings that Pluto is
not a planet is the same reason why I
misspoke sound about the New Horizons
mission
Bluto is picking weird Kuiper belt is a
ring of really loosely packed icy rocky
worlds out beyond the orbit of Neptune
and Pluto is the largest of the Kuiper
belt objects they're so far away we've
never studied the Kuiper belt object
except we kind of have and composed
roughly of the same stuff failure now we
know avoid a bit about frightening
because once upon a time its Neptune
backwards people think that it was
probably captured from the Kuiper belt
by Neptune as part of this weird solar
system changing event that happened like
four billion years ago in which Neptune
and Uranus switched places also
potentially causing destruction that's
like thousands of Pluto sized bodies
plus five news
there's the weirdest news and solar
system even know it had five moons until
pretty recently before New Horizons
wants he didn't know about
so now it's headed on its way to Pluto
and there's New Moon's to watch out for
and there may be more moons that we
don't even know about which actually
presents a danger the New Horizons could
crash into one of those moons which
would end the mission to be very sad we
wouldn't even know what happened because
we wouldn't be able to get any data
about it those moons were probably
collected from the Kuiper belt which
Berto spent most of his time and couple
of them have these weird wobbly or
that make it so that if you were on the
surface of them you would never know
when the Sun who's gonna come up
sometimes the Sun would rise in the east
and then like set in the North your eyes
insist on more than 4.5 million
kilometers away and to get there it had
to exit Earth's orbit faster than any
object ever has before
the budget on my tailing Jupiter I'm
having Jupiter like sucking forward just
beat it up even further he's going so
fast now that adverse it can never slow
down so it's just kind of blast past
Pluto and deeper into the Kuiper belt
since transmitting data from 4.5 million
kilometers away requires a lot of
fine-tuning New Horizons cannot take
pictures and transmit data at the same
time so as it approaches over the next
week it's gonna be taking pictures like
crazy but it won't be able to send us
any data since the transmission speeds
are so terribly slow slower than like an
early 90s modem it's gonna take months
for us to get all the data that we're
gonna get from this thing that is going
to give us a truly rich and deep end
understanding of this mostly unexplored
world I'm very excited John New Horizons
will be making its closest approach on
Tuesday so if you can put a picture on
the video about your friends and to get
really excited for everybody to see it
just like you excited for me to see the
fifth movie John oh we will of course be
covering the New Horizons mission like
crazy on scishow and I encourage you to
also check out our new series
specifically designed for elementary
school students crash course kids